17h30 à bord de son combi rétro anthony
simone les belles petites routes de
campagne
dans quelques minutes le service là
bientôt commencer c'est un concept qui
plaît beaucoup puisqu'à la fois on amène
une touche d'originalité avec un vieux
combi vintage conte à restaurer est
dedans on amène des bons produits mais
bien artisanal local et aussi des
produits sans alcool tout ça du point
une belle voiture des bons produits des
gens du point 3 c'est la recette du
succès ça se passe très bien avec son
ami cyril ces deux anciens collègues ont
décidé de changer de vie yves ya trois
ans en proposant ce bear trucks cinq
bières artisanales locales servis
directement depuis le flanc du combi sur
la place du village un égouttoir sur
mesure
avec intégrer un reims vers
suffit d'un raccord pour une évacuation
de l'eau 18 heures les premiers clients
sont déjà là et madame le maire n'est
pas la dernière pour venir en profiter
c'est la semaine du 15 août je sais pas
s'il y aura de monde mais y'a des fois
j'avais bien légère quand il fait beau
à dimona
de tout à fait faire plaisir aux gens
profitez du temps et puis faire
travailler tous nos petits commerçants
qui sont qui sont à côté qui demande que
ça surtout en ce moment mais je le but
principal c'est vraiment faire plaisir
aux gens dans un village où il ne reste
plus qu'une boulangerie ouverte le matin
et encore pas tous les jours ces soirées
foot trucks sont devenues un rendez vous
incontournable pour les habitants on
essaie de retrouver un peu de vie il
faut que ça bouge un peu c
mais c'est bien tous les 15 jours au
moins les gens sont un peu est ce qui
vous ferait plaisir
laframboise
laframboise on est du coup sûr une bière
plus tôt
c'est sur l'acidité du cheval on n'est
pas du tout sur le sucre très légère une
sorte de limonade à la framboise
est ce que vous venez chercher vous
voyez la boire chez vous c'est bien ah
bah non pas comme ça
chez nous c'est en bouteille c'est pas
voilà c'est passé c'est pas pareil donc
puis c'est bien là on vois du monde tous
partagent nous on a un peu loin de tout
y'a quand même parce que vaincus m
d'amboise 25 de tours donc du coup le
concept ambulant il se déplace il vient
là c'est comme un plus plus fait c'est
plus sympa et en plus c'est avec les
gens qu'on connaît donc s'est
ému c'est autre chose que d'aller en
ville à une terrasse on connaît personne
et pour participer à la redynamisation
des campagnes anthony a décidé de ne pas
en rester là il va développer son
concept à la franchise pour d'autres
régions en france
les deux blondes de jeu